hi guys sci-fi recapped here today I am
going to explain the film called mother
gamer spoilers ahead watch out and stay
safe the movie starts with a single
mother named Ben discussing her son owns
admission at an elementary school the
admission officer explains that ohm has
been selected in the waiting list and
they have to pay an administration fee
to register and hold his seat since the
fee is quite expensive Ben decides to
let go of the seat in the next scene Ben
takes Elm out for dinner where she
scolds him to work hard next time and
get selected directly being a single
mother it's difficult for her to pay all
the expenses alone thus she wants her
son to get a scholarship and be good at
his studies although own got a 97 out of
100 he was only selected in the waiting
list the kid becomes sad so Ben takes
him to play arcade games in exchange she
asks Ben to promise that he will get
better scores next time now we are taken
forward to eight years where Ben is a
teacher at a school her son om is
already a teenager and has excelled in
his studies as he got the student of the
year award not only that he is also a
brilliant online gamer in fact he is so
good that he earns a lot of money every
month from his games he plays a game
named Arena of Valor and has a game
channel however Ben is unaware about all
this because she doesn't want her son to
focus on anything else than steady one
day his own plays inside his room Ben
knocks the door before she could enter
inside he stops playing and goes back to
studying on being asked by his mother
home describes that he is writing a
speech for Mother's Day He has been
selected to give a speech on the stage
at his school then own gives a form to
Ben saying he wants her permission to
let him enter an online game tournament
since his games have never affected his
studies until now he reassures that he
will keep focusing on his studies he
promises to play only during his free
time when he's not studying however Ben
refuses to sign the application
considering the fact that it will affect
his studies and his scholarship exam the
following day at her work Ben asks the
school's director to ban the use of
mobile phones in class since students
will be distracted then is quite old
school and is against students playing
games and spending too much time on
their phone hence she describes her
phone free classroom project to the
director elsewhere inside a classroom a
student named cobsack and his friends
play online games they are the last
benchers and troublemakers the teacher
catches them playing games and takes
them to the discipline officer since
copsack had a lot of complaints earlier
regarding his discipline the officer
gives him a final warning however
cobbsack who seems a bit of a brat
ignores the warning and leaves the
office after a few days Ben goes to alms
school to attend the Mother's Day event
and hear his speech inside she sees a
banner with Ohm's picture as the student
of the year While She Walks With Pride
towards the Event Hall she overhears
elm's friends talking about his online
games hearing them she realizes that a
few days back ohm was not writing the
speech but playing games when the boys
mention Ohm's gaming channel named Sonic
fighter she immediately searches it and
is taken aback afterwards when om runs
into her she scolds him for lying to her
and asks him to quit playing it is
revealed that ohm has been playing for
an online gaming team named Higher
Ground enraged Ben requests her son to
resign from the team or else she will
limit his phone use this makes om sad
and he leaves later when it's time for
the speech own goes missing then
searches for him everywhere at school
and at home but he's nowhere to be found
just then she gets a call from someone
named best soon she arrives at an online
game Institute of Higher Ground vest who
called her is the coach of Higher Ground
then approaches home and asks him to
leave the team and go back home however
best warns her that if she wants her son
to quit the team she is obliged to pay
compensation as per the contract then is
shocked to know that ohm has forged her
signature and signed the contract
furthermore best reveals that they have
been paying a lot of money every month
to om for his games if Ben terminates
the contract she has to pay the sponsor
of their team and until ohm is under
contract he will have to train with them
furthermore best mentions that Ohm's
team will compete in the National League
if they win they will represent Thailand
in a world tournament in South Korea on
February 8th hearing the date makes Ben
even more angry because ohm has a
scholarship exam the same day after the
mother-son returns home Ben yells at
home but the latter erupt mentioning the
fact that he earns more than her just by
playing games he also brings up the fact
that he has never let the games affect
his grades but still Ben never allowed
him to do what he likes since she always
forced him to be a bookworm he gets mad
at her and decides not to speak with her
until the tournament the next day Ben
comes up with an idea if om and his team
loses in the National Tournament they
won't be able to participate in the
International Tournament that way he can
prepare for his scholarship exam later
she searches through the internet to
find out about the competition as she
goes through the information she
discovers about cobbsack's team who has
won the championship twice while they
played with Higher Ground however they
were kicked out of the team because of
their aggressive attitude with this
information Ben goes to see cobbsack who
is also her student she convinces him
that she's starting an esport Club and
asks him to join with her being the
manager at first he is reluctant
claiming that he's busy with his studies
but when Ben promises to help him
graduate if her team wins the National
Tournament he agrees however cobbsack
has a condition where he will choose the
teammates himself to which Ben agrees
later that day cobbsack introduces his
teammates God Bank map rang and Max to
Ben although Max looks like a kid he is
actually a teenager since the tournament
rule doesn't require a manager cobsack
ensures that Ben will play as their
substitute player then names the team
his own Gaga soon the team starts to
play the first round of the online game
road to Arena of Valor and wins looking
at her team Ben is excited to beat her
son however the next day cobbsack calls
Ben to inform that guide has dumped them
and joined Higher Ground for a better
salary so cobbsack insists Ben to play
instead of guide without having any
choice Ben agrees to play while she is
traveling with her fellow teachers in a
bus she goes to the toilet and tries to
play the match however being a rookie
she is is not of much help to the team
nevertheless the team wins later Ben
meets her team who insists her to
practice the games soon they start to
train her day and night until she learns
minimum skills for the games it seems
like Ben is also having fun with the
kids elsewhere ohm and his team wins A
match but the coach best is mad at home
because he wasn't up to the mark he
warns him to not be overconfident and
stick with the team's plan while best
gathers his team and shows them the
previous match of own Gaga ohm is
shocked to find out that his mother is
playing with cobbsack in the following
scene there's a match between cobbsack
and Omen which home wins however he sad
that his mother is so desperate to make
him lose on the other hand cobsack is
disappointed to lose against ohm
meanwhile Ben arrives and talks to
cobsack about his grades she guides him
how he can manage to graduate with just
passing marks while she speaks cobbsack
realizes Ben has good timing skills so
he uses those skills in the game for
exact moments to attack and retreat with
Ben's help on Gaga is able to win the
round of 64 teams against the team
Killers the next day at school Ben's
phone free classroom project is
initiated all the students funds are
taken and they are asked to retrieve
them after school however cobbsack hides
in the washroom and practices for the
round of 32. sadly he is caught by the
discipline officer and his phone has
seized although he tries to convince the
officer that Ben has been helping him
with the game the officer doesn't buy
his excuse and refuses to return his
phone elsewhere cobbsack's friends are
worried because they can't reach him
since the match is about to start in an
hour map ring goes to cobbsack school
when she calls guide to ask about
cobbsec she finds out that Ben is
actually Ohm's mother soon she meets Ben
and asks her to find a way to get
cobbsack out while she finds a room with
Wi-Fi then Ben Rings the school's Bell
earlier than 6 pm and cobbsack manages
to run from the discipline office with
his phone meanwhile Ben and map ring
find a Wi-Fi signal at the director's
office and join the match after a few
minutes cobsack also arrives at the
office and they start to play while the
three play at school Max and Bank play
from their home just when they win the
match and cheer the director returns
back to his office with the discipline
officer they are surprised to see Ben
with cobbsack on being asked Ben
awkwardly replies that she is playing
games with the kids in the next scene
cobbsack and map rang learn about Ben's
truth they are mad at Ben for using them
to beat her son as a result they decide
not to play anymore and leave now with
no options left Ben applies for a loan
from the bank to pay the compensation to
Higher Ground for terminating the
contract she calls Baston informs him
that she's ready to pay the compensation
after a few days later that night ohm
returns home sad and bursts at his
mother asking if she ever wanted him to
do what makes him happy he breaks down
and goes to his room this makes Ben
emotional and rethink about her decision
the following day Ben goes to Max's
house and asks him to take her to
cobsack when she reaches cobbsack's
house she apologizes to him and informs
him that she has convinced the school's
director to set up an Esports Club at
school she further clams that she is
happy when she plays games with cobbsack
and his team therefore she decides to
play with them again to which cobbsack
agrees later Ben goes back home and
takes cobsack's Higher Grounds jacket
and arrives at the National Tournament
out of 16 teams only one winning team
will get the chance to represent
Thailand in the world championship in
South Korea inside the hall Ben meets
best and asks him to cancel her
agreement to pay the compensation
however he refuses to do so because he
had already removed on from the team
after her call soon the match starts and
Ben plays very well with her team
succeeding to reach the finals now they
have to play against Higher Ground while
Ben plays with her team home watches the
match in the audience the final match
starts with a round of five home wins
the first two rounds easily this makes
the higher grounds player hopeless of
winning the game and request their coach
best to get on back on the team with no
options left he reluctantly agrees in
the next scene ohm returns to play for
his team and competes with his mother
right after he starts to play Higher
Ground wins two rounds in a row now the
final round decides which team wins the
national league in the final round Ben
plays as the main lead of her team
against Elm who is the MVP of his team
the mother-son Duo give a competitive
fight to each other it seems like ohm
has lost the match against his mother
but turns out it's a trap soon Ben's
fighter in the game dies and the
national league gets its winner Ohm's
Higher Ground everyone cheers for ohm
and his team while they get the trophy
in the audience cobsack and his friends
acknowledge Ben's effort in the game
they thank her for being with them till
the end then watches her son with pride
who is jumping with joy after the
victory in the next scene we see Ben
watching an interview with om on TV
where he explains about esport moreover
he states that his mother has been an
inspiration to him and calls her his MVP
at the end of the movie we are taken to
cobbsack's school where the esport club
is set up with cobbsack as its president
subscribe and hit that like button to
help our Channel grow turn the
notifications on so you won't miss any
of our new videos thanks for watching